for two years we've brought you all the
sins we could find in movies now we're
bringing you a new kind of suit you
fondly we said since music videos are
crazy as hell
wait a minute on one yet this sin-free
girl playing a trumpet when the
instrument in the song is clearly a
saxophone also someone named alicat was
definitely cupping this chicks boo while
signing the shirt also honestly who
brings a trumpet to a drive-in let alone
multiple trumpet the response time of
the comic police is so slow that I'm
beginning to wonder if this is the best
use of our tax dollar is that more
product placement
turns out Nicki Minaj does have a
perfume it's called minajesty of course
it is it's said to smell like red
currant tiger orchid and semen the fact
that someone said you know what the song
needs another guitar solo
[Music]
hmm okay we found one music video
without sin otherwise we're gonna have a
field day
[Music]